[Music]
look out there out there is the perfect
life you see it I think so most people
can't Carroll Shelby
maybe Lee Iacocca Ford Motors suppose
henry ford ii wanted to build the
greatest race car the world's ever seen
to win the 24 hours of lamont what's it
take I'll take something money can't buy
you can buy speed what in about speed
you need a pure racer behind the wheel
of your car that's Kent miles I don't
trust him an inch we heard he's
difficult no no Ken's a puppy dog
now whatever it is she'll now trust me
you're gonna build a car to beat Ferrari
with a forward correct and how long did
you tell us that you needed to three
hundred years it's 90 days this isn't
the first time Ford Motors gone to war
we know how to do more than push people
go ahead girl go to war thank you sir
do you think you can beat Ferrari
lighter faster
that don't work for nastier
we're going back history
you ready I was born ready mr. Shelby
hit
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Elsa the past is not what it seems
you must find the truth
across the enchanted lands and people to
be unknown
but be careful
we have always feared houses powers were
too much for this world
[Music]
now we must hope
they are enough
[Music]
I won't let anything happen to her
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just talk to the kid you're magic like
me I need you listen to me the world's
hungry place a dark place
hi there I only met two or three people
like us they died
when I was a kid I bumped into these
things I don't know about magic I I was
called at the shining
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot Fred
we've discovered a third island we need
to put aside our differences and work
together to save the world from being
destroyed what we really need is a hero
actually that positions been filled
I have to get a team together we're
busting you out she's super smart and
why is she all over these achievement
award I just don't think this is gonna
work okay so what I'm usually angry
walks to herself
left-handed probably with fun being
alone back there okay guys step one
travel undetected to the island all the
gadgets you see here have been designed
with your current mission in mind first
Bing and visit spray how long does the
invisibility last for forever what we're
not gonna be able to see each other
[Music]
okay so what's the plan trust me I know
working with what we get
[Music]
Piggy's challenging is 12 great dance
battle
[Music]
oh it's on Wow - I don't know if I'm
gonna fit in your back anyone smell
bacon
you don't think women can do anything
just because they can doesn't mean they
should that's just the way out standing
angels you have a new client who is she
I can't sleep at night I'm the lead
programmer on a product that can
revolutionize the power industries but
there is a possibility it can be
weaponized and I'm not privy to I'm Jake
who are you embossing
welcome to the pounds of agencies we
exist because traditional law
enforcement can keep oh I don't like
that boy
they're like lady spies thanks former
mi6 oh god what did you do to spend my
compressed his carotid and deoxygenated
his brain stem well that sounds painful
don't worry he's gonna wake up unless he
doesn't Sabina runs the ground game
sanyo stuff let's get the weapon before
it becomes every bad guy's favorite new
toy take her to the closet cheer her up
we're gonna need some wigs toy
we're still in the first posit there's
another closet
just stop the touching some of these
blows up
[Music]
I love Fosters soon are you flirting
with a handsome nerd host No
[Music]
how'd that feel cuz it looked like it
felt really good I feel nice
[Music]
there's morning angels morning charlie
[Music]
some people believe if we repeat stories
often enough they become real
[Music]
they make us who we are Matt can be
scary
eat it Harold you want to see haunted
house some kids went missing so they
boarded it up
okay I saw it we go now ordered the
chicken what's that it's a book of scary
stories tell me a story
hey what's going on
Tommy's missing Tommy's name was in the
book there's no way it's actually
connected right okay what happens in the
book is exactly what's happened for real
oh my god listen you're in the next
story bringing it right here
[Music]
I'm afraid that we broke something up
we've got to stop it
sara bellows his book when the stories
write themselves and it all comes alive
the jingling man is coming
[Music]
I can't believe that in half an hour I
will be a part of the the Domus gaming
dynasty Empire Dominion we prefer
Dominion yeah I honestly can't wait to
be a part of your family there's just
one more thing and then you are
officially part of the family so at
midnight get to play game why it's just
something we do when someone new joins
the family a game what game
I didn't think are you really gonna play
that Wow the rules are simple you can
hide anywhere we then trying to fund you
so there's no way for me to win right
and stay hidden till dawn
no thank you good luck
[Music]
what the hell is this how old is this
thing I know you're in here sweetheart
you shot the maid she look like she's
wearing a giant white wedding dress
Emily seemed I had to play them off so
that I can get you out I think that the
claim for sunrise or something very bad
will happen to the family if we don't
find her and perform the ritual found
her - no your crossbow why don't you
just use mine
that's religious I just do just another
sacrifice
yes I didn't see where to get married
[Music]
please be a 5-star ride over yeah it
could be nice
hey let me guess you want me to drive
you to all the Sarah Connors in the city
haha Koreatown
No hold on gonna banger Yui here real
quick
nope don't got it just step on it please
hope like make it just a couple more
points as we got it
I've been dating this cop around and
we're on like cop missions where are you
[Music]
three red roses girl is thirsty
my buddy
I got this hello operator we need help
someone's trying to murder us
don't you know he was a complicated man
he's like blow jobs from the back you
know how hard that is I do
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the situation in the Pacific
is far worse than reported Pearl Harbor
is the greatest intelligence failure in
American history
the Japanese are planning something
bigger so what's the target
we believe it's Midway
Washington disagrees
Washington is wrong
today we're gonna be underdogs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe prove the American Navy isn't a
joke
[Music]
you'll remember this moment for the
rusty in life
so tell me have you done this a lot met
people on the computer service don't you
fine it's always the same you mean them
special for a violin that down but I'll
tell myself brace up this time it will
be different which is Rama's law
professor Europe a deception my daughter
my name is in fact not Brian it's Roy
[Music]
to the future how much challenge is
worth nearly 3 million combinations
there the lots you bloody bet I've gotta
take it off
is that your grandson it's too soon to
be getting so close to him
I've grown very fond of you do you know
who you are you're the only person on
this planet who makes me feel that I'm
not alone
I know things about you who you really
are you don't want to do this Roy
the adrenaline rush
[Music]
what if it is seems like you've had
quite a past enough to last several
lifetimes
and just a blink your life just forever
you know it's very peculiar doing things
you'd never imagine secrets between you
God the devil
and the dead you don't know him
[Music]
Thomas Alva Edison my boys and I caught
in a jar but before now is only flashed
across the night sky the future is here
oh I'm George Westinghouse Nikola Tesla
I will leave a great this provider
electrical power in the world better
than Edison there's a contest between
you this is a battle for the brightest
minds of America today the impossible
becomes possible and the man that
controls that current controls the
future I hope you brought your
checkbooks you want to be remembered
it's simple shoot a president but if you
prefer to have what I call a legacy you
leave the world a better place than you
found it you were building miracles out
of thin air I'm working on something so
new that the world would never be the
same if mr. Edison succeeds he will send
us back so far we may never recover
sometimes we have to work outside of the
rules to get was right
that is how you truly win it oh you got
bulges in every venture but did I
mention that his systems lethal his
current kills people he's playing dirty
you can too
you can't see the real force that moves
things and it's a CD sales of torrents
it's a card saying this is costing a
forged Westinghouse time my mother that
is our future you fired and there were
gonna be anything named Tesla ever again
our futures not going to pay for the
bricks for recovering I had the better
system Westinghouse Electric shall
endure the City of Light but I built it
already in my imagination it is perfect
there is a possibility you'll be putting
in jeopardy the lives of 28 million
people tonight things could change
shake up her right
only one man would rise
so what'd you trade inventory fix
problems readyit's where are you
recreate insisting Chapel in this boy's
room not that right
you should be knee-deep in a sofa with
some great as ice wherever he goes I go
whatever you say officer look what's
happening it's hard give me the
defibrillator
[Music]
let me handle it took my wife dirty cops
where you go I'm gonna kill him
[Music]
[Music]
it's a video game
Oh [ __ ] grown-up man I don't play
video yeah well maybe you should try to
help you with your aggression scene I'll
do anything for my family
this is [ __ ] than anything as it gets
but bring him to us and you'll get your
wife back
you're gonna mail her you're going to
jail you just say stupid [ __ ] all the
time I'm going to jail you're coming
with me
I want back ten powers and the remans
detail can you get the [ __ ] out of the
car please I have pepper spray in my
purse
they ever go to my points
what are you thinking about
I do what I do because of my dad he was
a hero he gave his life for the pursuit
of knowledge control getting that over
[Music]
it's crazy out there there's fires
everywhere and plane crashes they're
calling it the search major we have some
highly classified information
what can you tell us about the Lima
project its objective was to search for
advanced extraterrestrial life the ship
disappeared approximately 16 years into
the mission and the commander was it was
my father Sir this might come as quite a
shock to you
your father was experimenting with a
highly classified material that could
threaten our entire solar system all
life would be destroyed we're counting
on you
to find out what's happening out there I
worry about you you love you please
begin your psychological evaluation as
best you can please describe your
current mental and emotional state I am
feeling good ready to do my job to the
best of my abilities
and remain fully committed to the lawful
completion of the mission if necessary I
will destroy the project in its entirety
the earthquakes hopes in him
and now it's fake based on me
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
what we know is that to them has this
material we don't know that I mean he
just keeps repeating the line just
because you're the Prime Minister it
doesn't mean you get to make up your own
facts
someone in this building has betrayed
their country
if you are found to have withheld
information you will be charged with a
breach of the Official Secrets cousin
come did you think like this because
remember all you this friend be careful
this is real you do the jokes for having
in your possession you're a spy you work
for the British government
no I work for the British people I do
not collect information so that the
government can lie to the British people
intelligence may be being manipulated to
take this country to all this stop
taking Tony Blair at face value
you had nothing to gain and everything
to lose this could result in a prison
sentence do you want to risk it all
[Applause]
everywhere every country biggest
demonstration in human history if we do
not go public we would be conceding that
no one who ever told the people when
their government is lying
[Music]
we did extraordinary the public is
entitled to know why my motives stop war
and save lives
I have to tell the truth what brings in
today I have a hard time focusing get
enough sleep every night how much is
enough six to eight hours
Oh way more than that I had a friend she
was prescribed done at her role and now
she's very alert you know some people
abused that or all right let's get you
healthy I want you to try losing 55
pounds that's the weight of a Siberian
Husky you want me to pull a medium-sized
working dog off of my body it's trying
to feel like everyone's lives are going
places and the mind sort of stuck hold
it hold it please try not to leave all
your stuff in the hallway
that'd be the third time this month
change is possible if I keep
interviewing no one thinks I'm the right
fit I would love you to walk me through
CPR or this doll oh I'm sorry this child
was dead I need to get a teeny bit
healthier we have raised as low as 129
dollars you do know that people can run
outside that is zero block
today you do that somebody chasing you
over did you do doing it sorry I'm
talking baseball my sister she owns a
company house and pet sitter all right
I'll stay bad taste in music you're the
new girl I'm the nighttime guy Jaron I'm
done with the drinking I'm don't like
this 50,000 people from around the world
are racing today I want to run the New
York City Marathon I think that is such
a good idea thank you so much I'm really
good at making profiles God woman it's
not that bad I'm just gonna give you
mine okay do you know how to spell
herpes
[Music]
my whole life the world told me I was
lazy because the way I looked was trying
to turn my life around everything's
gonna be fine people help doors for me
how old doors for you you changed your
life was never about your weight was
about you taking responsibility for
yourself
[Music]
you